[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mon travail consiste en quelque sorte à transformer la
femme en consommatrice, il y a beaucoup de
censure autour des organes génitaux masculins et je
pense que c'est en partie parce que nous avons l'habitude
de le voir comme une piqûre menaçante si
nous  continuez simplement à représenter la forme féminine
encore et encore et il n'y a pas assez
d'équilibre en ce qui concerne la
représentation des hommes que je pense que nous perpétuons en quelque
sorte cette idée des femmes en
tant qu'objets à consommer l'un de celui
de la série I  'ai travaillé s'appelle
soif cette idée que la série utilise en quelque sorte
des hommes pour orner des objets fonctionnels,
ce que j'ai fait si souvent avec
des corps de femmes, ce qui perpétue en quelque sorte
cette objectivation de la forme féminine
[Musique]
cette série a en quelque sorte commencé comme  cette
idée très directe de présenter une
perspective féminine et un fantasme féminin que nous
ne voyons pas vraiment dans les médias grand public,
y compris la pornographie, puis cela
s'est en quelque sorte transformé en ce portrait
comme glorifier les hommes en fête
à travers le cunnilingus, comme tout mon travail,
la série consiste à rejeter cette idée
de la passivité féminine comme je pense que les femmes
ne sont pas passives, nous sommes en quelque sorte et
ça l'accepte aussi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que la culture est en quelque sorte une partie énorme  de
mon éducation en grandissant, vous avez l'
impression qu'il y a deux choses que je peux
contribuer à la société et c'est soit
comme mon Seigneur depuis la sexualité ou moi en tant que
mère a commencé à se rebeller contre cela c'est
devenu un artiste et et ouais c'est comme
presque cette colère que j'ai ressentie  être
regardée et objectivée, mais aussi
ne pas avoir d'autonomie, cela
me semblait presque interdit en tant que femme
d'utiliser le sujet pour utiliser l'
humour grossier dans mon travail, il y a beaucoup de
censure autour des organes génitaux masculins et je
pense qu'une partie  c'est parce que nous avons l'habitude
de le voir comme une chose menaçante et
je pense que c'est en partie parce que nous ne le
décrivons pas assez, vous savez, je pense que si
vous continuez à le voir, vous perdez en quelque sorte
son pouvoir sur nous notre  cu  La lture a
tendance à punir les femmes
Je pense que les femmes intériorisent tellement cette culture
de la slut-shaming que vous savez que la
slut-shaming n'est pas seulement pour des actions mais
juste pour l'expression de la sexualité mon
travail fait tout ce que je voulais juste amener
les gens à remettre en question leurs réactions
leurs idées  leur jugement